hi und herzlich willkommen bei ZDF heute
live ich freue mich dass ihr
eingeschaltet habt und Lust habt mit uns
zu diskutieren habt ihr euch schon mal
gefragt wo euer Strom eigentlich
herkommt also klar aus der Steckdose
aber quasi eine Ebene vorher aus welchen
Energiequellen setzt sich der Strom
zusammen da gibt es eine ganze Menge
Kohle Windkraft Atomkraft und im
aktuellen Strommix ist eine ganze Menge
dabei vielleicht habt ihr aber schon mal
den Begriff dunkelflaute gehört der
taucht in den letzten Tagen und Wochen
immer mal wieder in der
Medienberichterstattung auf und
tatsächlich befinden wir uns in
Deutschland gerade in so einer
dunkelflaute das heißt ganz grob es ist
sehr dunkel und sehr windstill und das
sorgt dafür dass Deutschland vermehrt
auf fossile Energie Zulieferer wie Öl
oder Kohle setzen muss um den
Energiebedarf zu decken ich zeige euch
das mal hier bei mir auf dem PC damit
wir das besser nachvollziehen können
ihr könnt da ganz gut erkennen das ist
quasi unser Strommix aus dem sich der
Strom zusammensetzt und diese graue
Fläche diese relativ große graue Fläche
das ist Erdgas dunkelbraun ist
Steinkohle und hellbraun ist braun coole
ja und ganz abgeschlagen da unten da das
gelbe das ist Fotovoltaik und blau ist
Windenergie also das sind so ein
bisschen die erneuerbaren Energien und
deren Anteil ist gerade wie gesagt nicht
hoch ja was diese dunkle Flaute für
unsere Versorgungssicherheit aber auch
für unser Klima bedeutet und wie wir uns
in Deutschland in Zukunft
energietechnisch aufstellen müssten
darüber diskutieren wir heute mit euch
und mit Simon Müller er ist Direktor
Deutschland beim Think Tank agora
Energiewende und mit Volker quatschinken
er ist Professor für regenerative
Energiesysteme an der Hochschule für
Technik und Wirtschaft Berlin ganz
wichtig sind aber natürlich wieder eure
Fragen eure Kommentare und Anregungen
zum Thema stellt eure Fragen gerne hier
in Youtube äh direkt in den Chat oder
schreibt uns gerne auch eine Mail per
Mail an ZDF diese minus live als zdf.de
lass uns jetzt aber erstmal noch mal
darauf gucken was so eine dunkelflaute
genau ist das erklärt uns jetzt Carsten
heckes
bisher zeigt sich der Dezember vor allem
so kalt und dunkel das mag zunächst nach
üblichen Winterwetter klingen stellt die
Stromversorgung Deutschlands aber vor
große Probleme denn noch im dritten
Quartal dieses Jahres wurde das deutsche
Stromnetz zu 43% mit erneuerbaren
Energien bespeist etwa drei Viertel
davon gewonnen als Wind und Solarenergie
liefern Wind und Sonne aber über einen
längeren Zeitraum wie jetzt nur wenig
Energie fehlt in Deutschland Strom
experten sprechen in diesem Fall auch
von einer dunkelflaute dass wir derzeit
eine solche dunkelflaute erleben zeigt
auch der Vergleich mit den Vorjahren
während die erneuerbaren Energien im
Dezember der Vorjahre noch ein Drittel
des Energiebedarfs mit regelmäßig mehr
als 500.000 Megawattstunden Strom Decken
für diesen Dezember bislang mit nur
knapp 370.000 Megabyte Stunden im
Durchschnitt lediglich ein Fünftel des
Bedarfs gedeckt im Netz fragen sich
deshalb viele ob Windräder und
Solaranlagen zuverlässige
Energieproduzenten sind
die Lösung der Regierung konventionelle
Energiequellen wie Kohle und Gas müssen
her um den deutschen Energiebedarf zu
decken
ja darüber wollen wir heute sprechen und
zwar unter anderem mit Simon Müller
Direktor Deutschland beim Think Tank
agora Energiewende hallo Herr Müller
schön dass Sie bei uns sind hallo
schönen guten Abend ja wenn ihr Fragen
habt schickt uns die gerne wie gesagt
hier im Chat oder per Mail der Herr
Müller wir haben es gerade gesehen diese
dunkelflaute sorgt ja dafür dass wir
mehr fossile Energien zu Stromerzeugung
brauchen wie klimaschädlich ist das denn
was da gerade nötig ist also zunächst
mal müssen wir uns anschauen dass das ja
nur um relativ kurzen Zeitraum geht ja
also ein oder zwei Wochen vielleicht ein
bisschen mehr aber auf das ganze Jahr
betrachtet liefern die erneuerbaren
Energien sehr zuverlässig Strom
inzwischen ungefähr die Hälfte unseres
gesamten Stromverbrauchs wenn wir mit
den Emissionen runter wollen ist es
deswegen also ganz wichtig dass wir
schneller werden beim Ausbau der
Windkraft schneller werden beim Ausbau
der Photovoltaik also den Solaranlagen
auf den Dächern und auf den Feldern und
so können wir dann auch eben die
Abhängigkeit von fossilen Energien
beenden
ja Herr Müller hat gerade schon
angesprochen das ist quasi aufs Jahr
gezeigt relativ kleiner Zeitraum ich
zeige euch aber trotzdem mal auf meinem
PC wie viel co2-equivalente da gerade
für die Stromerzeugung freigesetzt
werden wir haben hier so eine ganz
schöne eu-karte und da sieht man
Deutschland steht im EU-Vergleich nicht
so gut da äh das ist diese braune Fläche
und dunkler also schlechter in Bezug auf
CO2 äquivalente ist eigentlich nur noch
Polen daneben wir haben Bulgarien die
sind zugleich auch die sind so ungefähr
gleich auf mit Deutschland das heißt
schlechter als hier steht eigentlich nur
Polen da Herr Müller sie haben ja gerade
gesagt das ist nur ein kurzer Zeitraum
das wirkt jetzt aber von dieser Karte
trotzdem so als ob wir eigentlich uns
nicht mehr als Klima Vorreiter
bezeichnen können sondern in der
Hinsicht in diesem Zeitraum gerade eher
Klimaschutz ist Schlusslicht sind in
Europa oder also die Karte zeigt auf
jeden Fall wie wichtig der Kohleausstieg
in Deutschland ist es gibt ja ein Gesetz
dass der passieren soll bis 2038 aber
wir bei agora Energiewende sagen der
soll früher kommen spätestens 20 30 und
dass das so wichtig ist das sieht man
eben an diesen emissionszahlen weil
Kohle ist eben ein wahnsinnig
schmutziger Energieträger und deswegen
im Moment so stark nutzen naja da ist es
nicht ungewöhnlich dass wir mal ein paar
Wochen haben mit wenig Wind und Sonne
das wissen wir seit Jahrzehnten das ist
das immer wieder gibt in einem
Erneuerbaren Stromsystem aber wir haben
ein anderes Problem wir haben erstmal
dieses sehr große Problem das Russland
die Gaslieferung eingestellt hat das
heißt wir müssen mehr auf Kohle setzen
weniger auf Gaskraft im Stromsystem das
zweite ist der Klimawandel macht sich
die Klimakrise macht sich bereits
bemerkbar wir haben weniger Wasserkraft
verfügbar auch das hatten Effekt auf die
Kraftwerke die verfügbar sind und der
dritte Grund ist Frankreich hat massive
Probleme mit seinen Atomkraftwerken
zwischenzeitlich waren weniger als die
Hälfte der Kraftwerke am Netz verfügbar
dieses Jahr auch jetzt fehlt deutlich
mehr als ein Drittel und das hat unter
anderem damit zu tun das Ding
Konstruktionsfehler haben und deswegen
aufwendig repariert werden müssen das
heißt wir haben eine ganze Reihe von
Problemen die zusammenkommen Deutschland
hat auch tatsächlich in den letzten
Jahren
an Tempo verloren beim Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien hätten wir dort
weitergemacht wo der Ausbau der
Photovoltaik 2011 gewesen ist wo der
Ausbau der Windenergie 2017 gewesen ist
dann hätten wir heute deutlich deutlich
besseren Strom Mix
ja es wurde gerade schon kurz
angesprochen frankreich hat massive
Probleme mit der Atomenergie trotzdem
ist diese Debatte die wir gerade führen
ja für einige Menschen immer wieder auch
der Aufhänger zu sagen diese dunkle
Flaute zeigt jetzt Energiewende
schwierig wir können es uns eigentlich
in Deutschland nicht leisten auf
Atomenergie zu verzichten wie stehen sie
denn dazu ich würde das anders sehen die
aktuelle dunkel Flaute das gehört ganz
normal dazu wenn man einen erneuerbares
Stromsystem aufbaut was braucht man
dafür um damit umzugehen man braucht
regelbare Kraftwerke die man ein und
ausschalten kann aber das Wichtige ist
dass die eben nicht mit fossilen
Energien laufen sondern auch mit
gespeicherten Erneuerbaren wie
funktioniert das man kann in den Zeiten
wo es beispielsweise im Sommer am
Wochenende sehr sehr sonnig ist wenn es
im Herbst so ein Herbststurm gibt und
ganz viel Wind Strom verfügbar ist dann
schickt man denen ein sogenannten
Elektrolyseur der spaltet Wasser auf und
macht daraus Wasserstoff und diesen
wasserstoff kann man gut speichern und
dann Kraftwerke regelbare Kraftwerke
laufen lassen in solchen Wochen wie
jetzt und so kriegt man nun 100%
erneuerbares Stromsystem hin also wir
brauchen Atomkraftwerke nicht um ein
Stromsystem aufzubauen was klimaneutral
ist und übrigens ist es so die Länder in
Europa Frankreich und Finnland unter
anderem die gerade Atomkraftwerke bauen
die stellen fest das ist deutlich teurer
als erneuerbare Energien und es dauert
sehr lange teilweise 10 20 Jahre immer
wieder ist es zu Verzögerungen gekommen
erst jetzt bei dem Kraftwerk in Finnland
das hätte schon seit vielen Jahren am
Netz sein sollen aber es wird immer
wieder aufgeschoben das heißt die
Technologie ist relativ teuer ist
ziemlich langsam umgebaut zu werden
erneuerbare sind da günstiger lassen
sich auch schnell zu bauen was wir jetzt
halt tun müssen ist es gibt eine Reihe
von von Bremsen die diesen Ausbau noch
zurückhalten und da muss die Regierung
einfach deutlich mehr tun damit der
Ausbau schneller wird
ja das Thema
Atomkraftwerke Atomenergie scheint
unsere Community zu bewegen hier fragt
YouTube User Hoffmann was wäre denn
passiert wenn wir die Atomkraftwerke
abgeschaltet hätten
also man muss sich das anschauen man
misst diese Leistung in in Gigawatt ja
nur so zum Vergleich da geht es ungefähr
um 3 Gigawatt Leistungen auf Seiten der
Atomkraftwerke in Deutschland alleine
die die in Frankreich fehlen sind so
zwischen 20 und 25 Gigawatt die dort
fehlen und die Gesamterzeugung in
Deutschland ist ungefähr bei 80 also was
bedeutet das das bedeutet der Beitrag
der deutschen Atomkraftwerke ist bereits
sehr sehr gering wir sind praktisch fast
fertig mit dem Ausstieg aus der
Atomkraft und das was im Moment in
Frankreich fehlt schlägt viel viel
stärker ins Gewicht als das bisschen was
in Deutschland gerade noch läuft
ja lasst uns doch mal auf die
dunkelflaute gucken unser Wetterexperte
beim ZDF ist den terli hat sich die mal
wettertechnisch angeguckt und gecheckt
was da in der ersten Dezemberhälfte so
los war
im Vergleich zu den vergangenen
Jahrzehnten haben wir jetzt relativ viel
Sonnenschein gehabt es war fast die
Hälfte die zu erwarten wäre in den
ersten zwei Wochen des Dezembers ist
tatsächlich 46 % gewesen ja und wenn man
das aufdröselt auf die einzelnen
Großstädte nehmen wir sie mal als
Beispiel dann haben wir in Hamburg
normalerweise 36 Stunden im langjährigen
Mittel und jetzt im Dezember in den
ersten zwei Wochen waren es 21,7 also
gut 22 Stunden in München sind es 67
Stunden normalerweise und 18,5 sind es
bisher gewesen und in Berlin weniger
kann man durchaus sagen 45 Stunden
normalerweise und jetzt sind es 11
Stunden aber jetzt kommt der Wind ins
Spiel in der zweiten Monatshälfte wird
es ordentlich wenn ich jetzt bis zur
nächsten Woche zum Beispiel bis Mitte
nächster Woche bekommen wir regelrecht
Sturm und das schauen wir uns mal hier
auf der Karte genauer an und wir sehen
hier dass ein Sturmtief aufzieht ja und
es bleibt auch bis in die Mitte der
Woche größtenteils windig und das
wahrscheinlich auch bis zum Ende des
Monats ja und zum Vergleich zu den
ersten zwei Wochen ist es so dass ja das
jetzt die nächsten zwei Wochen sehr
wenig sein werden vorher war es einfach
recht ruhig
ja das vielleicht noch mal zu Erklärung
dieses Phänomens was ja wie Herr Müller
auch schon gesagt hat eigentlich gar
kein neues Phänomen ist sie haben jetzt
gerade gesagt der Ausbau der
Erneuerbaren ist eigentlich das wo wir
besser werden müssen das hilft jetzt
aber wahrscheinlich nicht in einer zwei
drei jahresperspektive oder
doch auf jeden Fall das kann bereits in
zwei drei Jahren helfen gerade im
Bereich der Photovoltaik das kann man
sehr schnell zubauen und wir sehen auch
dass immer mehr Leute das von sich
heraus auch tun wollen also die Zahlen
für sogenannte balkonkraftwerke gehen
steil nach oben das also Leute bei sich
zu Hause das selber installieren aber
auch bei den Anlagen auf den Dächern und
auf den Feldern ist im Moment eine
deutliche Steigerung zu sehen ähm im
Bereich der Wind Energie ist es so da
haben sich über die letzten Jahre so
nach und nach Bremsen angehäuft ja die
also den Ausbau hemmen da geht's vor
allen Dingen darum dass die Bundesländer
zu wenig Flächen zur Verfügung stellen
für die Windenergie so viel braucht man
gar nicht aber der Prozess hängt einfach
hinterher
und das andere ist die Prüfverfahren die
sehr wichtig sind für den Naturschutz da
sind die Regeln unklar und es dauert
auch sehr sehr lange und das muss jetzt
sich ändern und dann ist es auch möglich
dass die Erneuerbaren deutlich schneller
zugebaut werden
natürlich ist es so wir haben aktuell
die Versorgungskrise mit Gas da müssen
wir auch schauen wie wir kurzfristig
Ersatz beschaffen das klappt auch
bereits indem wir flüssig Erdgas vom
Weltmarkt zu kaufen wo man da wirklich
aufpassen muss jetzt ist dass man nicht
zu viel von diesen Ersatz Lieferungen
beschafft weil ansonsten sitzen wir auf
etwas Garten was wir gar nicht mehr
brauchen wegen der Klimaziele ist es
nämlich so dass schon in acht Jahren
unser Gasverbrauch deutlich zurückgehen
muss und deswegen ist es wirklich nur
eine kurzfristige Zwischenlösung
ja sie sprechen schon Thema an über das
wir auf jeden Fall gleich noch sprechen
kann man denn irgendwie so einschätzen
wir haben jetzt lange russisches Gas
importiert das gibt es nicht mehr jetzt
importieren wir Flüssiggas aus anderen
Ländern wie ist das denn so im Vergleich
sind die gleich klimaschädlich oder ist
da eins schlimmer als das andere das
kommt darauf an wie das Gas gefördert
wird insgesamt muss man darauf schauen
wie viel Methan entweicht ja also das
ist im Grunde genommen der
Hauptbestandteil von Erdgas und das ist
auch klimaschädlich das ist zwischen 20
und 80 mal so klimaschädlich wie CO2 und
wenn bei der Förderung und beim
Transport Methan entweicht ist es
tatsächlich ähm klimaschädlich wenn wir
es anschauen dass wir aktuell flüssig
Erdgas beispielsweise aus den USA
beziehen dann ist es so dass das über
Fracking gewonnen wird wo höre CO2
Emissionen damit verbunden sind das
zeigt wir müssen wirklich das so weit
wie möglich minimieren wie viel Gas wir
jetzt einsetzen und eben auf Lösungen
setzen die uns frei machen von fossilen
Energien dazu gehört der Ausbau von
erneuerbaren da haben wir schon sehr
viel darüber gesprochen aber man kann
auch über
Energieeffizienz sehr viel erreichen
viel Erdgas brauchen wir gar nicht im
Stromsektor sondern viele Leute heizen
damit und man kann da zum Beispiel mit
Wärmepumpen auch die Wohnung heizen das
ist deutlich effizienter und dann
brauchen wir insgesamt weniger Gas aufs
gesamte Energie System geschaut
wir haben hier eine user-frage die auf
jeden Fall noch mal in anderen Bereich
so zum ganzen Thema
Klimaschutz Klimakrise übergeht und zwar
verkarren Hofmann auf Youtube auf einmal
haben wir zu wenig Energie und alle
sollen Elektroauto fahren können Sie Ihr
sagen wie das zusammen passt
ja also zunächst mal ist es so dass der
Umstieg auf Elektroautos sehr viel
Energie einspart
normales Auto verliert ungefähr zwei
Drittel der Energie durch Abwärme das
kennen wir alle der Motor wird heiß und
das ist tatsächlich Energie die im Öl
eigentlich drin ist aber die dann
verloren geht das bedeutet der Umstieg
auf Strom selber der erhöht die
Energieeffizienz deutlich was aber
stimmt wir brauchen für diese
Elektrifizierung sauberen Strom und
deswegen ist es ja so wichtig dass die
Regierung jetzt alles daran setzt dass
der Ausbau der Erneuerbaren schneller
vorangeht
und wir haben noch eine weitere Frage
aus der Community und zwar auch auf
YouTube von Agent 47 hier gibt es auch
noch mal ein Verständnisproblem hallo
was bringt uns so viel Photovoltaik und
Windkraft wenn wir die Energie in der
dunkelflaute brauchen was machen wir
damit den Überkapazitäten
ja also im Grunde genommen funktioniert
es so wir haben in bestimmten Momenten
haben wir Überkapazitäten beispielsweise
an einem sonnigen Sommerwochenende oder
während dem Herbststurm und was wir da
brauchen sind halt diese elektrolyseure
und davon bauen wir mehr und mehr zu das
fängt jetzt erst so richtig an und über
die nächsten Jahre muss das wirklich
krass ansteigen und was wir dann machen
ist wir schnappen uns den Strom wenn
viel davon vorhanden ist und machen
daraus Wasserstoff und das tolle an dem
wasserstoff ist dass man den gut
speichern kann den kann man in
Salzkavernen einspeichern und dann in
diesen dunkel Flauten tatsächlich wieder
zurück in Strom verwandeln das ist die
Lösung für dieses Dunkel Flauten Problem
das haben wir schon seit vielen vielen
Jahren verstanden was wir jetzt einfach
tun muss müssen ist diese Lösung auch
umzusetzen
okay also innovative Wege quasi Energie
zu speichern und wir haben hier noch mal
eine Frage von YouTube und zwar fragt
Jack young können die Ziele ich denke
mal es geht um die Klimaziele denn
überhaupt noch erreicht werden
das ist eine sehr gute Frage unsere
Einschätzung nach reicht das was die
Bundesregierung auf den Tisch gelegt hat
aktuell nicht aus um die Klimaziele
einzuhalten im Koalitionsvertrag haben
sich die ampelparteien darauf geeinigt
dass sie im ersten regierungsjahr ein
Klimaschutz Sofortprogramm vorlegen was
alle Maßnahmen enthält die gebraucht
werden um die Klimaziele in 20 30 also
minus 65%
Treibhausgasemissionen im Vergleich zu
1990 also um dieses Ziel zu erreichen
ein Maßnahmenpaket zu machen und das
fehlt die Regierung hat das bis heute
nicht vorgelegt es wird auch äh nicht
passieren noch dieses Jahr das heißt die
Regierung hängt beim Klimaschutz
deutlich hinterher und da muss jetzt
dringend 2023 nachgelegt werden weil so
langsam schließt sich tatsächlich das
Fenster um unsere Klimaziele noch zu
erreichen
ja und von der großen Metaebene den
deutschen Klimazielen gehen wir jetzt
noch mal weiter in diese
speicherthematik da hat sich offenbar
jemand schon mal näher mit dem Thema
befasst und fragt auch auf YouTube
Gregor fragt man kann ohne dich den man
kann ohne Speicher den Ausbau nicht mehr
viel weiter treiben wo sind die Speicher
projektiert und wie lange werden die
Speicher in der Größe von
Terawattstunden brauchen bis sie
verfügbar sind
also zunächst mal wir sind noch in der
Situation in Deutschland wo wir deutlich
mehr erneuerbare zu bauen können ohne
dass wir zusätzliche Speicher dafür
benötigen warum weil wir halt in den
ganz normalen Stunden übers Jahr
verteilt noch nicht bei 100%
erneuerbaren sind übrigens auch in
dieser dunkelflaute ist es so die
Erneuerbaren sind ja immer noch da ja
normalerweise kriegen wir knapp die
Hälfte von ihnen im Moment über die
letzte Woche betrachtet ist es immer
noch knappen viertel und selbst beim
Wind wir haben es eben gesehen ist noch
ein Drittel gelaufen obwohl es sehr
niedrig gewesen ist also das bedeutet
dieser Zubau der bringt tatsächlich was
da brauchen wir auch noch nicht sofort
Speicher zu bauen also die Erneuerbaren
müssen da nicht warten was aber passiert
ist die Leute selber bauen im Moment
speichern fast jede Photovoltaikanlage
zu Hause wird inzwischen mit einem
heimspeichert und jedes Elektroauto ist
ein Speicher auf Rädern dass wir
brauchen ist dass Netze intelligenter
werden so dass die Leute mit ihrem
Speicher zu Hause eben auch in seiner
Situation wie jetzt in den Stunden wo
wir besonders viel Strom brauchen auch
das Netz unterstützen können
ja danke Herr Müller dass sie sich den
Fragen unserer Community gestellt haben
vielen Dank dankeschön
wir gucken jetzt auch noch mal auf ein
Thema was gerade in dieser Debatte total
viel besprochen wird und das sind die
flüssiggasterminals auch bekannt als
Ellen g-terminals von den soll er in den
nächsten Jahren ganz schön viel
aufgebaut werden in Deutschland in
Lubmin ist z.B heute so ein schwimmendes
LG Terminal in den Hafen eingelaufen und
morgen wird ein anderes Terminal in
Wilhelmshaven eröffnet und ziel dieser
Terminals ist ja immer die
Unabhängigkeit von russischem Gas durch
wir haben es gerade schon gehört Importe
von flüssigem Erdgas aus dem Ausland das
kann aus den USA sein voraussichtlich ab
2026 auch aus Katha es gibt aber eine
Studie die kritisiert jetzt dass das
aktuell viel zu viele Terminals im
Planung sind sollten nämlich in vier
Jahren sämtliche Anlagen in Betrieb sein
wird die Jahreskapazität von den beiden
73 Milliarden Kubikmetern Erdgas liegen
und das ist viel zu viel sagt das new
kleine mit Institute das ist eine
Energiewende Denkfabrik Widerstand an
den LG terminals in Deutschland aktuell
ist das hat sich Kai Bremen für uns
angeschaut
um kurz nach 16 Uhr legt das
Spezialschiff Neptun im Industriehafen
von Lubmin an hier soll das 280 Meter
lange Schiff in Zukunft als
privatbetriebenes schwimmendes Terminal
für Flüssiggas fungieren zwar stehen die
Genehmigung noch aus doch es wird nicht
das einzige LNG Terminal bleiben aktuell
werden insgesamt 6 Terminals an vier
Standorten realisiert ein synch
Brunsbüttel einzeln Stade und jeweils
zwei in Lubmin und Wilhelmshaven dort
kam schon am Donnerstag das Schiff Höck
Esperanza an und soll am Samstag als
staatliches lng-terminal feierlich
eröffnet werden
ja das Wort der Stunde Flüssiggas jetzt
begrüße ich aber erstmal Volker
quaschning er ist Professor für
regenerative Energien an der Hochschule
für Technik und Wirtschaft Berlin schön
dass Sie bei uns sind schönen guten
Abend wenn ihr fragen habt an Volker
quaschning dann stellt die gerne
jederzeit bei Youtube im Chat oder per
Mail schreibt uns einfach eine Mail an
ZDF
heute-live@zdft.de wir haben gerade in
diesem Beitrag gesehen wie sinnvoll ist
sind diese lng-offensive die in
Deutschland da gerade passiert
na ganz ohne Terminals wird es nicht
funktionieren wir haben im letzten Jahr
55% unseres Gases aus Russland bekommen
das fällt jetzt aus bekannten Gründen
weg und dafür brauchen wir natürlich
neue Wege wir haben einen Teil dieses
Gases auch durch andere Lieferungen aus
Norwegen aus anderen Ländern in Europa
decken können aber nur ein kleineren
Teil das heißt wir müssen jetzt von
anderen Ländern auch Flüssiggas
importieren und da hat man jetzt
panikartig sehr sehr viele Projekte auf
den Weg gebracht ohne sich glaube ich
ganz durchzudenken ob man dann am Ende
über die nächsten 20 Jahre auch alle
Projekte brauchen und so wie es aussieht
hat man doch jetzt mehr Projekte als
wenn im Prinzip brauchen das heißt
flüssiggast Terminals ja wir werden
welche brauchen ist die frage nur ob es
wirklich so viele sind wie momentan
geplant und gebaut werden sollen
jetzt gibt es ja auch Stimmen die sagen
gut wir wollen ja in Deutschland
eigentlich weg von fossilen
Energiequellen das ist eine
Übergangslösung und diese LNG Terminals
kann man ja dann auch easy umbauen und
sie für grünen Wasserstoff nutzen ist
das wirklich so einfach ja das ist immer
so eine Geschichte die man ganz gerne
erzählt also wenn wir schauen wenn die
LNG Terminals die alle geplant sind
kommen und voll ausgelastet sind werden
wir da erheblich mehr Flüssiggas
importieren als wir importieren dürfen
um unsere Klimaschutzziele zu erreichen
und dann haben wir nun zwei Sachen
entweder wir
schaffen die Klimaschutzziele nicht oder
wir werden die flüssige Gastherme nicht
auslasten können und vernichten damit
ein Haufen Geld und dann wird jetzt
behauptet naja wir könnten ja einfach
statt Flüssiggas flüssigen Wasserstoff
über diese Terminals importieren oder
andere Energieträger nun sind die
Anforderungen bei den Importen komplett
unterschiedlich ja also wenn ich jetzt
Flüssiggas habe das liegt bei minus gut
etwas über -160 grad vor flüssiger
Wasserstoff braucht viel tiefere
Temperaturen -150 90 Grad das heißt also
da habe ich auch ganz andere
Anforderungen an die Terminals an die
Leitungen und wir wissen auch gar nicht
ob wir den Wasserstoff in Form von
flüssigem Wasserstoff dann bringen
werden oder ob wir auf andere
Energieträger zurückgreifen zum Beispiel
Ammoniak Ammoniak wiederum ganz andere
Temperaturen ist auch ein ätzendes Gas
was also hier wieder andere
Materialanforderungen hat und je nachdem
was ich nun importieren möchte
Flüssiggas Wasserstoff oder Ammoniak
brauche ich eigentlich ein komplett
anderes Terminal und die
umbauaktivitäten für so ein Flüssiggas
Terminal wären enorm und dann muss ich
die Energieträger ja noch vom Terminal
wegkriegen momentan habe ich nur ein
Erdgasanschluss wie man Wasserstoff oder
Ammoniak von den Terminals dann in
Deutschland verteilen will dass es auch
noch gar nicht geklärt also hier ein
ganz ganz großes Fragezeichen
ja viele Fragezeichen und ich habe noch
mal ein paar Zahlen für euch damit ihr
vielleicht noch mal besser versteht wie
dringlich diese Fragen eigentlich
geklärt werden müssen denn allein bis
2035 müsste unser Erdgasverbrauch um die
Hälfte sinken und 2045 dürfte dann
eigentlich von uns kaum noch Erdgas
genutzt werden wenn wir die Klimaziele
erreichen wollen wir haben ja eine Frage
an Sie und zwar vom YouTube-Kanal Atomic
Ja oder Nein Frage an Professor
quaschning kann Deutschland ohne Abgang
der Industrie seine ganze Primärenergie
aus Erneuerbaren erzählen sie dürfen
aber gerne noch zwei drei Sätze
hinzufügen genau also die Studien zeigen
eigentlich dass wir ein Großteil im
eigenen Land aus Erneuerbaren decken
können in der Größenordnung von 80%, wir
werden ein Teil der Energie importieren
müssen also in Form von Wasserstoff oder
wasserstoffhaltigen Energieträgern die
studien sagen Lage sagt so Größenordnung
20%, das ist deutlich weniger als wir
heute importieren heute sind wir auf
etwa 70% importer angewiesen also
insofern wird Deutschland ein riesen
Stückchen unabhängiger werden
ganz unabhängig vermutlich nicht weil
der wasserstoffbedarf dann der Industrie
und aber auch das Flugverkehrs ist dann
schon sehr gewaltig und da werden wir
vermutlich nicht alles in Deutschland
erzeugen können weil die Akzeptanz
einfach für Windkraftanlagen und für
Photovoltaikanlagen dann so große Mengen
vermutlich nicht zulässt
ja und wir kommen hier nochmal auf die
AKWs zu sprechen die scheinen die
Community auf jeden Fall zu bewegen es
gibt hier ein Statement Statement von
YouTube User an der sagt ohne die AKWs
hätten wir schon den ersten Blackout wie
ist denn ihre Einschätzung dazu ja das
ist natürlich vollkommener Quatsch also
wir haben ausreichende Kapazitäten an
konventionellen Kraftwerken also ein
Viertel der Energie kommt ja immer
derzeit noch auch in dieser dunkelflaute
aus erneuerbaren Energien und für den
Rest haben wir auch ausreichende fossile
Kapazitäten wie exportieren ja momentan
also sogar noch kleine Mengen an Strom
weil Frankreich sich mit ihren
Kernkraftwerken nicht selber versorgen
kann also insofern die
Versorgungssicherheit ist nach wie vor
gewährleistet in Deutschland da haben
wir uns auch vor dem Winter keine großen
Gedanken gemacht und wie Herr Müller
schon vorhin gesagt habe die
Kernkraftwerke Decken drei bis vier
Gigawatt an Leistung das ist ähm relativ
wenig also wenn da ein ganz schwacher
winterpustet dann liefern die
Windkraftanlagen schon mehr und insofern
hat die Kernenergie keine große Rolle
etwas mehr für die Energieversorgung und
deswegen können wir auch ganz gut dann
auch im nächsten Jahr darauf dann
verzichten
ja wir haben es fuhren mit Herrn Müller
schon so ein bisschen
angerissen wir müssen auf jeden Fall ja
noch eine Weile Kohle und Gas verstromen
in solchen dunkelflauten Herr Müller
meinte aber wenn man jetzt wirklich
hinterher ist beim Ausbau erneuerbarer
Energien sein könnte das schneller gehen
als man denkt was ist denn ihre
Einschätzung wie lange müssen wir das
noch machen also fossile Stoffe wie
Kohle und Gas verstrom bevor es dann mit
Erneuerbaren klappt
das Ziel der Bundesregierung ist es ja
den Strombereich schon vor 2045
klimaneutral zu machen und die gesamte
Energieversorgung wir haben ja nicht nur
Strom sondern auch Wärme Verkehr und
Industrie dann 20145 komplett mit
erneuerbaren Energien zu versorgen für
das Einhalten des Pariser
klimaschutzabkommens müsste es auch noch
früher passieren eigentlich also müssten
spätestens Ende der 30er Jahre komplett
klimaneutral sein das hängt davon ab wie
schnell wir werden jetzt mit dem Zubau
erneuerbare Energien das heißt die
letzte Bundesregierung hat den Ausbau
der solaren Windenergie regelrecht
zusammenbrechen lassen und das brabelt
sich jetzt wieder ein bisschen wir
müssen das ganze aber für vier für fünf
für sechsfachen und da sind die
Vorzeichen relativ gut dass gerade bei
der Solarenergie sich viel passiert beim
Wind müssen wir noch ein bisschen tun
aber ich habe ganz gute Hoffnung dass
wir gerade jetzt mit der Energiekrise
verstanden haben das ist wirklich
wichtig ist dass Deutschland sich
unabhängig macht und deswegen könnten
wir in den nächsten zwei Jahren das
Tempo erreichen und dann sind auch 20 40
oder 20 45 für die komplette
Klimaneutralität Strom Wärme Verkehr
durchaus realistisch
wir hören ja immer Ausbau erneuerbarer
Energien es geht immer viel darum dass
in den letzten 16 Jahren nicht so
richtig viel passiert ist vielleicht
können wir das noch mal so ein bisschen
konkretisieren dass ich die Menschen
darunter mehr vorstellen können was
heißt das also mehr Photovoltaik mehr
Windkraftanlagen und vielleicht auch
mehr Speicher wie sieht es da aus ja
also wir haben ja verschiedene
erneuerbare Energien wir wissen dass die
Wasserkraft die Biomasse und die
Geothermie in Deutschland nur begrenzte
Potenziale haben die werden nicht mehr
wie 20% decken können deswegen wird der
Löwenanteil aus der Windenergie und der
Photovoltaik kommen müssen und wir
werden dann eine Energieversorgung
künftig haben wo Solar und Windenergie
70 80%, dann der gesamten Energie also
Strom Wärme und Verkehr Decken dazu
müssen wir natürlich einiges noch
zulegen wenn wir uns den gesamtkuchen
anschauen da liegen die Erneuerbaren
heute derzeit erst noch bei 20%. das
heißt also wir müssen das für vier für
fünf Sachen was wir momentan haben und
dann wird sich Deutschland aber auch
komplett Erneuerbaren mit diesen
Energieträgern versorgen und was wir
vorhin schon gesagt haben natürlich
müssen wir auch parallel Speicher bauen
aber das sehen die Studien vor diese
Sachen haben wir auf dem Schirm
ja das sind ja alles auch große
politische Entscheidungen und Maßnahmen
die da gebraucht werden gibt es den
irgendwas was man in diesen Bereich
quasi auch als Einzelpersonen machen
kann um da effizienter zu sein um dem
großen Ganzen so ein bisschen weiter zu
helfen
wir hatten erstmal in den letzten Jahren
sehr viele Widerstände die den Ausbau
erneuerbare Energien gebremst haben also
das können wir uns auf Dauer auf Dauer
nicht leisten weil jedes Windrad was uns
fehlt macht uns jetzt Probleme in diesem
Winter das heißt also wir müssen hier
die Akzeptanz auf dem Land auch für den
Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien haben
und natürlich kann jeder auch selber
beitragen also werden einen Eigenheim
hat kann eine Solaranlage aufs Dach
setzen man kann die Gasheizung muss
rausfliegen wir müssen auch uns von den
Verbrennungsmotoren von den Autos
verabschieden wenn ich eine Mietwohnung
habe kann man immerhin eine Solaranlage
an den Balkon hängen man kann sich bei
bürgergenossenschaften beteiligen und
wie gesagt ganz wichtig dass wir
wegkommen von den fossilen
Energieträgern sowohl im Autoverkehr und
auch der Flugverkehr und wenn das in der
Übergangszeit dann fliegen nicht klappt
Klima neutral das wird noch ein bisschen
dauern dann wäre es auch ganz gut den
einen oder anderen Flug einfach zu
unterlassen weil da haben wir wirklich
ein enorm großen klimafußabdruck mit
jedem Flug den wir betätigen und
verursachen
wir haben hier nochmal eine starke
Meinung aus der Community da gibt es
noch mal eher ums Thema LNG und zwar
sagt auf Youtube Rainer Struck so lange
die Tanker die das Gas transportieren
mit Öl bewegt werden ist das alles total
bescheuert können Sie das verstehen
selbstverständlich also LNG ist aber wie
gesagt es ist fossiles Erdgas was von
der Klimabilanz nur ein Tick besser ist
als die Cola also wenn ich jetzt von
Kohle auf Gas wechsele dann ist
irgendwie der der Wechsel von der Pest
zur Cola war das heißt wir müssen
natürlich schauen dass wir das fossile
Gas loskriegen und in einer
klimaneutralen Welt müssen sich
natürlich auch Flugzeuge und Schiffe
Klima neutral bewegen das heißt wir
müssen auch in den nächsten 20 Jahren
die Schiffe umrüsten das heißt da gibt
es schon Bestrebungen z.B mit Ammoniak
was aus Wasserstoff aus Strom aus
erneuerbaren Energien gewonnen wurde
dann auch Schiffsantriebe zu betreiben
oder auch mit Flüssigkeit aus oder
flüssig Wasserstoff das heißt das ist
technisch möglich das ist kein Problem
und dann kann man auch den Wasserstoff
den wir vorhin angesprochen haben den
wir dann in Ländern mit außerhalb von
Europa mit Solar und Windstrom
herstellen dann auch mit Schiffen
transportieren die dann auch Klima
neutral unterwegs sind also insofern
kann man das ganze schließen so dass
dabei auch keine CO2 Emission mehr frei
werden
wir haben ja auch noch andere Stimmen
aus der Community die vielleicht auch
noch mal so ein bisschen eine andere
Thematik in dieses über Thema Energie
mit reinbringen und zwar sagt auf
Youtube Alex Eisenerz die Leute haben
Probleme über die Runden zu kommen da
denken die doch nicht an CO2 ist doch
albern und auch Julia görling sagt bei
Facebook ist mir total egal woher mein
Strom kommt Hauptsache ich habe Strom
woher ist mir egal ob AKW Kohle oder
Wind
naja wir müssen zwei Sachen sagen also
erstmal warum haben wir jetzt Probleme
über die Runden zu kommen ne also
Deutschland hat keine Energieträger Öl
und Gas und wir haben eine
Energieversorgung aufgebaut die uns
komplett abhängig gemacht hat und
deswegen haben wir ja diese enorme
Energiepreise weil wir einfach drauf
gesetzt haben die Energiewende langsam
zu machen während wir bei der
Energiewende weiter und hätten jetzt
doppelt so viel erneuerbare Energien
dann könnten wir uns ein Stück weit
zurücklehnen und hätten gar nicht die
Probleme die wir haben und dann würden
die Leute auch nicht das Problem haben
über die Runden zu kommen also insofern
ist das eine sehr fatale Aussage und wir
wissen dass die Klimakrise Kosten
verursachen wird die wir uns heute gar
nicht vorstellen können wenn die in
vollem Umfang zusteht und das wird
natürlich auch irgendjemand bezahlen
müssen das heißt also nicht schnell den
Klimaschutz zu machen wird für
Deutschland so teuer werden dass wir am
Ende unseren Wohlstand damit verlieren
und insofern ist es glaube ich doch
enorm wichtig wenn man nicht noch enger
den Gürtel schneiden muss jetzt wirklich
die Hände die Ärmel hochkrempeln die am
Ende dann zu nehmen und auch anzupacken
und das zu realisieren und nicht zu
sagen naja es wird schon alles gut weil
das wird uns noch weiter in die Krise in
die Katastrophe führen und nicht aus
dieser Krise heraus
und wir haben hier noch mal ein
Kommentar oder eine Meinung aus der
Community von Hans-Jürgen Wolter auf
Youtube der sagt die Atomkraftwerke die
man hat sollten laufen bis es passt
lieber die Kohlekraft rausnehmen würde
das funktionieren
also wir kriegen die Kohlekraft die
Atomkraftwerke jetzt gar nicht mehr zu
laufen wir haben jetzt noch resturan das
ist im April
ausgebraucht die Kernkraftwerke sind
sicherheitstechnisch gar nicht mehr
genehmigungsfähig die müssten erstmal
alle in die Revision da sehen wir in
Frankreich das kann Jahre dauern bis die
dann dort wieder laufen und ähm dann
müsste man Uran bestellen was man auch
nicht innerhalb von drei Monaten bekommt
also insofern ist es komplett
unrealistisch selbst wenn man wollte
dass man die Kernkraftwerke jetzt dann
im nächsten Winter z.B auch noch zur
Verfügung hätte und wie gesagt die
Energiemengen sind relativ gering wir
reden über 1,2% des gesamten Energie
Aufkommens den die Kernen Energie deckt
und dann müssen wir doch einfach mal ein
bisschen Tempo weil so laden Windenergie
machen dann lässt sich das auch relativ
ruckzuck ersetzen das heißt also das
bisschen Kernenergie rettet uns nicht
über den Winter es hilft uns nicht
Energie unabhängig zu werden es drückt
kaum die CO2 Emissionen und äh sorgt
auch nicht dafür dass die Kosten
signifikant sinken die keine Energie ist
ein ganz ganz großes Ablenkungsmanöver
sie haben ja die letzten 16 Jahre
Fehlern der Energiepolitik gemacht und
weil viele Kreise eigentlich nicht
wollen dass wir über diese Fehler reden
wird jetzt einfach permanent mit der
Kernenergie hausieren gegangen die aber
nicht hilft vielleicht mal eine Zahl
wenn wir wollten dass die Kernenergie
wirklich signifikant zum Klimaschutz
beiträgt und vielleicht die Hälfte
unserer Energieversorgung deckt das
bräuchte man ja vielleicht um auch
wirklich vom CO2 runter zu kommen dann
reden wir nicht über den Weiterbetrieb
von drei Kernkraftwerken sondern das
über den Neubau von 100 Kernkraftwerke
innerhalb der nächsten 10 Jahre dann
würde ich gerne von den Leuten die also
auch das gerne möchten mal die Liste der
Standorte hören und dann mal sehen wie
das funktioniert ich halte das für
komplett absurd und unrealistisch und
deswegen sollten wir diese Diskussion
beenden sie sorgt einfach nur dafür dass
wir Zeit verlieren beim Klimaschutz weil
wir über ja neben Kriegsschauplätze sage
ich mal in dieser ganzen Diskussion
diskutieren und den Fokus von den
wesentlichen Sachen verlieren wir müssen
uns darauf fokussieren die
Energieanlagen die Solaranlagen und
Speicher auszubauen und nicht über
irgendw den virtuellen Kernkraftwerke
die nie kommen werden und auch die drei
die uns nicht wirklich helfen werden zu
diskutieren das lenkt nur ab und hilft
uns nicht bei den großen Problemen
ja 100 Atomkraftwerke das ist auf jeden
Fall eine ganze Menge wir haben hier
noch ein Kommentar zum Thema Solar und
Wind und zwar sagt Michael freier ihr
könnt ja mal versuchen mit Solar und
Wind zu heizen
ja selbstverständlich also wir wissen
dass wir die Gasheizung rausreißen
müssen ich meine alle Leute die jetzt in
eine Gasheizung haben schreien ja
derzeit nach gas-subventionen wir decken
mit Staatsgeldern die Gaspreise runter
wir werden im nächsten Jahr 80
Milliarden Euro an Geldern verbrennen
die wir einfach für die Subvention
fossiler Energieträger verwenden und das
ist doch kein guter Weg also das kann
doch irgendwo nicht die die Wahrheit
sein natürlich müssen wir auf
elektrische Energie setzen und da ist
die Idee die elektrische Wärmepumpe zu
nehmen die elektrische Wärmepumpe
wandelt Strom enorm effizient in Wärme
um und im Vergleich zu einer Gasheizung
spare ich da ja ein Drittel zwei Drittel
bis dreiviertel an Energie ein das heißt
alleine dadurch dass ich die Gasheizung
durch eine Wärmepumpe ersetze geht der
Energiebedarf um 60 80% runter und das
verbleibende was da noch übrig bleibt
das müssen wir dann mit Strom aus Sonne
und Wind machen das müssen wir super
bauen aber da die Wärmepumpe so
effizient ist ist das gar nicht so so
richtig kompliziert und deswegen ist es
so enorm wichtig auch von der Gasheizung
wegzugehen und da hat die Regierung
nicht schnell genug aber einiges richtig
gemacht sie hat also jetzt dann die
Regeln so gesetzt dass wir weniger
Gasheizung einbauen dürfen werden wir
dem dänischen Weg gefolgt hätten wir
diesen Winter gar keine großen Probleme
in Dänemark ist es seit 2013 schon
verboten neue Öl und Gasheizungen
einzubauen und das hat dieses Land
natürlich wesentlich unabhängiger jetzt
gemacht von dem Gas diesen Weg hätten
wir folgen müssen dann hätten wir jetzt
nicht die Probleme die wir jetzt haben
und mit denen wir kämpfen
vielen vielen Dank dass Sie sich den
ganzen User Fragen gestellt haben und
vielleicht an einigen Stellen für
Klarheit gesorgt haben ich fasse mal
zusammen mit einem Kommentar von YouTube
User Alien 23 der sagt ich bin so
gespannt auf den Winter 2023 da gibt es
bestimmt einige wir bleiben aber bei ZDF
heute live dafür euch dran ich freue
mich dass ihr so emlich gefragt habt
vielen Dank noch mal Herr quaschnik und
wenn ihr mögt bis bald
[Musik]